in this world there are heroes and there  are villains last year as the world  focused on your failures Boston Celtics  complete the four-game sweep of the  Brooklyn Nets who saw friends become  foes and others cement their place in  history without you questions arose from  those watching as your legacy became  riddled with doubt  the foundations of your surroundings  started to crack  massive breaking news Brooklyn Nets GM  Sean marks is working with Kevin Durant  finding a trade  is it all worth it you may never know  but in order to reach the Pinnacle once  again  it's time to make a choice we've got  some breaking news Kevin Durant needs to  remain with the net just a lot of  uncertainty was built some doubt in my  mind about the next four years of my  career you can be the destroyer of this  league  or you can be its savior